[Music]
you know this whole question around
tolerance and empathy and understanding
and where the limits are is a very very
tough conversation and I come down in an
odd place on the one hand I think we
have to defend very aggressively the
most vulnerable constituencies in
America Muslims immigrants transgender
people LGBT women African Americans
low-income people and I think you have
to be aggressive about it I think you
have to be passionate about it I think
you have to be serious about it if we're
gonna have liberty and justice for all
and not liberty and justice for some
then we got a lot of work to do and I
think that's important at the same time
there sometimes can be a loss of empathy
for those constituencies that may feel
that they have to give up something to
get to equality for those of us who are
trying to gain something to get to
equality we can be very passionate and
it feels good we're making up lost
ground over you know generations of
discrimination we're overcoming that it
feels great for other people even just
psychologically they may feel that
they're losing ground and it's sometimes
hard for us to have much empathy for
that and we tended to go into well you
know shut up you know you guys have to
game to yourselves you
disproportionately the business leaders
and the Senators and everything else and
it's our turn and shut up
and that's totally understandable it
just may not work very well because
change is hard for people if you're a
liberal you look at gentrification
here's a neighborhood that used to have
african-americans or Latinos or whatever
and then you go away for five years
usually come back and here you know the
hipsters have come and they set up their
kale shops and bikes things every
you're like hey yeah it's like Oakland
California right now West Oakland is
being completely transformed by its
proximity to Silicon Valley and people
who work for Google and all these places
are now moving into West Oakland totally
changing the place I sometimes look at
that night go hey hold on a second I
like Oakland the way it was you know and
if I can build a wall around Oakland and
make Silicon Valley pay for it I might
consider that because I liked Oakland
the way that it was now that doesn't
mean that we should close the borders of
the trumpet's right I'm not saying that
at all I think we need more immigration
not less and I think we need a a faster
pathway for us to steal all the best
talent from around the world and the
hardest workers rather than slower I
think of America's is it gets to compete
better because we get to cheat and get
all the good people from everywhere here
but can I have a bridge of empathy and
understanding to somebody who says hey
wait a minute III liked America the way
that it was when I grew up I I liked
certain things I've got some grief now
I've got some anxiety now I've got some
some fear now does do we have to call
that person a bigot do we have to say
that person is a morally deficient human
being and push them outside of the
circle of decent company or is there
some way for us to say we don't agree
with you we see it differently but we
can understand why there might be some
anxiety here and by the way you might
want to prepare yourself because more
change is coming we're gonna keep
pushing for more change on gender on
sexuality on the demographic so more
change is coming and we but we get it
sometimes I think people just want to
want to be witnessed in their struggle
without being judged and condemned these
are tough conversations to have you know
and you start talking like I'm talking
you're going to get hit from all sides
I'm willing to do it because I just
don't think you can have an honest
conversation in the other way and the
of having a democracy with 300 million
people in it every color every human
every faith every gender all that's
actually working together I mean it's
worth having some tough conversations
and going through some rocky periods to
get to that outcome but our intolerance
for the intolerant may actually create
more intolerance our tolerance for the
intolerance may leave in place too much
intolerance so it's a catch-22 that you
can't get through with just your brain
your heart has got to lead to some place
where you can actually hold on to your
principles and hold on to your neighbor
at the same time that's the challenge no
easy answer but that's what we got to
try to do
[Music]